perfetto allora questa è la lista delle
cose da portare questa è la lista dei
posti da visitare
qui abbiamo i ristoranti dove mangiare
infine qui c'è la stima approssimativa
di quanto spenderemo non conta nulla
sì devo fare il calcolo prevedere quando
mi dire il ciclo bercy dove finisce
proprio il giorno prima di partire che
culo ma la vita è imprevedibile falco ma
iniziano domani adesso vivente e bruno
trova danza un volo solo andata per la
sicilia 400 euro ma siamo pazzi mie ma
come non avete più posto è il
cinquantesimo albergo cucchiani ma che
me ne frega se siamo in quattro e pc
cagotto io da domani toilet aria ma una
domanda ma tu un posto in camper ce
l'hai ancora no perché ti dico mi andava
proprio di andare in camper contato e ce
ne sono vacanze prenotate perché noi
facciamo 30 metri che siamo nelle stesse
più belle al mondo
poi abbiamo visto alloggio pagati gli
amici migliori di sempre quelli di una
vita è poi il cibo buono che proprio non
ce lo imita nessuno è infatti non tutti
sono fortunati come noi non tutti
nascono nel sud amo è che ci devi fare
vacanze paganese pala ma se siamo solo
amici a sessione devo dare un milione di
esami cosa studiare ancora tutti sono
nella merda figure contempo io di
cercare e prenotare ma la parte che se
non passò ludica esami miei mi chiudono
in casa auto gava cans amo dopo ne hanno
chiuse in casa non è che voglia di fare
festa voglio proprio spaccarmi a merda
cioè voglio dì moderni anche i cessi
voglio bene anche le pozzanghere cia io
voglio fare così tante serate che la
spiaggia ma ancora riuscirò a vedere
capito già ideali quanti aster faremo ma
quale hai capito fra un po essere nuova
canzone di marina noi non vedo l'ora di
pompa armerà nelle caste e acea d'oro
finalmente libertà io e la mia valigetta
siamo pronte per due settimane di
meritatissima solitudine perché
viaggiare da soli a 100.000 o altre
meglio niente parenti invadenti niente
armi che di merda che ti rubano i
fidanzati e niente con
sedi di lavoro che ti mettono se avrò
modo di conoscere persone nuove di fare
nuove esperienze e soprattutto non devo
rendere conto niente a nessuno di quello
che voglio fare mangiare e visitare
vacanze sono un po ma anche quest'anno
il massimo tra vacanza però sbloccarmi
sul divano con una vaschetta di gelato
il ventilatore sparato in faccia è
proprio quello sarà il momento l'apice
del lusso non importano le mete
paradisiache per andare in vacanza
basta respirare a pieni polmoni
riscoprire il contatto con la natura non
avere orari non avere scadenze leggere
un buon libro
la vacanza è uno stato interiore che
dura tutto l'anno e importante
rigenerarsi per ripartire più carichi di
prima
gli hotel è perfetto le proprio davanti
al mare abito sì sì sì ho già provato
praticamente colazione pranzo c'era
tutto incluso la camera di bambino mi è
leggermente spostata ok in modo tale che
se voglio fare bim bum bam con antonio e
non mi sentono rapito è perfetto e il
mini cup
aspetta un attimo tesoro tt richiamo
subito senta mi sono dimenticata
richiede ma il miniclub c'è ma voi siete
tutti i trulli ma è impossibile che non
ci sia un mini sarebbe in una struttura
dei generi ma voi avete idea come fanno
le mamme in vacanza ma lei una madre per
caso ecco lo sapevo ma raga tranquille
organizzati voi lo sapete che io ho di
organizzare cioè mi fido di voi
veramente ibiza di nuovo ma dai che in
aria sempre lo stesso posto a serve l
assist e rabbia in campeggio in sardegna
mona ti prego
cioè io c'ho 10 pt chiese 5 valigie
tifare capri in campeggio a casa di
sarah con i genitori a roma sei pazza
naimi rifiuto affittare una casa in
quattro ma tu hai idea di quanto
possiamo spendere amo non mi ha buttato
giù ma cos'ha detto di male a